The nice thing about the Java remote object model is that much of the
heavy lifting that an application programmer has
to do in building a client-server system using
RPC. Things like marshaling, unmarshaling, publishing the
remote object on the network for the
clients to access. They're all subsumed under
the covers by the Java distributed object runtime.
And this is where one can see the
similarity between the subcontract mechanism in the spring system
that we saw recently, which was the origin in
some sense for the Java RMI. Before we dig
deeper, let me give you at a high
level the distributed object model of Java. The term
remote object in the object model of Java, refers
to objects that are accessible from different address spaces.
And the term remote interface is used in
the distributed object model to say what are all
the declarations. For methods in a remote object. Once
you have a remote object the interface, remote interface
is saying what are all the declarations for
methods that are existing in the remote object that
are accessible from clients anywhere. That's what remote interface
is. And then the distributed object model of Java,
the clients have to deal with RMI
exceptions. So that's the failure semantics of the
distributive model that the clients have to
deal with exceptions that might happen when a
remote method is invoked by a client.
And there are some similarities and differences between
local objects in Java and remote objects. The
similarity is that you can pass object references
as parameters when you make a an
object invocation. An object invocation arguments of the
invocation could include object references. That's the similarity,
but the difference is that the parameters. When
it is passed, it is passed as
value result. That's the difference between local object
and, and remote object. In the case of
local object, when you pass an object reference
as a parameter, then the method that is
invoked can reach into that object that has
been passed as a parameter as a reference
and make modifications to it and that modifications
will get reflected. In the original object but
in the distributed model, because the object references
are passed as value result. If going across
a network, that is passed as value result meaning
the copy of their object is actually sent over to the invoked method and that
invoked method is seeing the copy of the object and it is even though there is
a reference being given. But the reference
is actually converted into value result in the
parameter passing mechanism for the distributed object model.
So that's a fundamental difference in parameter passing.
So they're both similarities in the sense that you
can pass object references as a parameter. But the
difference is the reference is passed in a value
result mode, as opposed to a pure reference. So, in
other words, once an object reference has been passed
as a parameter to the server. If the client
makes changes to that particular object whose reference is
being given in the invoked method, those changes, the server
will not see it, because that is
local to the client. That's fundamentally different
from between the local object model of
Java and the distributed object model of Java.